so I met three really cute dogs today
first we had Hefty the bulldog who was
indeed very Hefty super cute very loving
then we had meatball who was just a
total ham I love meatball next we had
Penny who was just the prettiest girl
I've ever seen she was adorable this is
so hard you guys I loved Hefty he was so
cute but I just feel like he was a
little too how do you say it
rambunctious but you know what he kind
of left me smelling a little like dogs
Penny and meatball super sweet dogs I
can tell that they have great owners but
at the end of the day I think that Penny
was just a little bit mellow for me I
like to have fun and that's why I'm
gonna pick meatball because meatball was
just a joy to play with a joy to see and
I'm really excited to see who owns
meatball hi I'm Janine how are you
Alicia thanks for picking meatballs so
what do you think do you want to go on a
date yeah I'd love to